معنا من اوديسا نتاليا المتحدثه باسم
قياده عمليات الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني
اهلا وسهلا بك سيده نيويورك هذه الصواريخ
الامريكيه اذا مات سلمتها اوكرانيا ما
الذي يمكن ان تغيره في سير المعارك
م طيب يجب ان نفهم ان تغيير مسيره الاحداث
والمعارك هذا لن تقم به الصواريخ بل
القوات والجيش الاوكراني نحن نطالب
بصواريخ بعيده المدى لماذا لان الجيش الذي
يحارب ضدنا هو جيش مستعد لحرب طويله المدى
وهم لديهم يد طويله ونحن نحتاج
لقدرات تسمح لنا بضربات بعيده المدى حتى
نقص
ذيل هذا الجيش وهذه الصواريخ اذا ما تمت
الصفقه طبعا ستكون
برؤوس مزوده بقنابل عنقوديه وليس براس
حربي واحد هل هذا تطور مهم بالنسبه لكم
لانها ليس من المهم او الاساسي ان يكون
هناك رؤوس نقديه ام لا بالنسبه لنا الاهم
هو القدره على توجيه ضربات بعيده المدى
حتى لا يكون لدى العدو قدرات ان يقوم
بعمليات من مسافات بعيده وحتى نتمكن وحتى
لا يتمكنوا من امدادات قواتهم بالذخيره
وحتى يعلم وانهم لن يستطيعوا
بالثقه بامنهم وحتى يتراجعوا عن الحدود
الاوكرانيه ذات الاهميه العالميه والمعترف
بها منذ عام 91 ولكن هذه الصواريخ بعيده
المدى السيده هومنيوك ستعني عمليا ان كياب
اصبحت باستمرار تضرب العمق الروسي وهذا
عليه بعض التحفظات لدى الدول الغربيه
سوف سوف ندمر قدرات العدو وذخيرته
بحيث نحرر اراضينا ومناطقنا باسرع وقت
ممكن اوكرانيا ليست مهتمه وليست حريسه على
تدمير روسيا او توجيه ضربات لها وهذا ليس
هدف موضوع امامنا ان روسيا هي من جاءت الى
اراضينا لتدمير اوكرانيا واوكرانيا تريد
ان تدافع عن اراضيها وارادتها وحريتها
واستقلالها بالنسبه لنا من المهم طرد
العدو من مناطقنا واراضنا وان نجدد حدودنا
وسيطر عليها وان لا نسمح لاي احد ولا في
اي وقت من الاوقات التعدي عليها بالنسبه
لاستهداف مقر الاسطول البحري الروسي في
القرن
ما الذي تتوقعونه بعد هذه الضربه
صح النوم
ننتظر انهم سوف يفهمون جيدا اننا نعلم
جيدا اين هم واننا سنستطيع وسوف نستمر في
تدمير كل ما هو موجود بطريقه غير قانونيه
على اراضينا ان الوجود وجود مركز
الاسطول البحري للعدو على اراضينا هذا شيء
غير قانوني ولهذا
حصلوا على ضربتين
ولكن هل تخشون
ردا انتقامي
كبير بعد هذه الضربه
بعد
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير عام 22 ليس
هناك اي انتقام جديد ممكن ان يقوم به
العدو ضد هذه الدوله التي لم تقوم باي عمل
ضدها نحن نفهم جيدا انهم ينتقموا منا حتى
وان لم نقوم باي اعمال هل تفهمون هذا فهم
بداوا بهذه الحرب ضدنا فقط لاننا نعيش
بطريقه التي نعتبرها سليمه
شكرا جزيلا لك نتاليا المتحدثه باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني